it was written but my point is that she
went into the other room and she started
when you i said go in there you can
change and as you made your way into
that room you were singing to yourself
and always but my friend uh jeff is here
with his lovely wife dana and dana went
oh my gosh she has a beautiful voice of
an angel
that's what she no you weren't talking
like that you were just singing and i go
you know she is a singer
she is a singer in fact she has a single
outro
we heard you sing though one time on agt
did they have you do like a whole yeah
she dropped from the moon and sang with
the the guy we can uh
you have a clip do you have a clip of
that
yes we'll show that you know what's
funny you had a singer as a mel b was
there at that time right they didn't ask
me singers real singers just don't want
to sing go figure don't call yourself so
people who are not real singers they
want to sing all the time
performance right there i sang with sal
sal was my golden buzzer who click on
that click on the one heidi klum
performance so this was uh especially we
did yeah that one
so this is her christmas special we did
for america's got talent right and they
asked me if i would do a duet with my
golden buzzer cell
and you don't have to ask me twice to
sing so i'm like hello to the yes yes
singing santa baby give it up for south
africa
a santa buddy that's not if you're
listening
she makes your voice
[Music]
[Applause]
socks
[Music]
we got it so that's you singing and
she's singing live
as she was singing live dana loved that
dana but do you remember this when we
actually did this because this was taped
and we did this and i come down on my
candy cane and i'm supposed to do my bit
yeah and i completely black out and i
couldn't remember it do you remember
this i didn't remember that you blacked
out
that was scary it was so scary because
i'm already like you know i hate
heights yeah i know i i fly with her a
lot of places yeah cries i do i cry a
lot on airplanes actually once we drank
a lot and i opened this um champagne
bottle and it popped on your head
not so funny if i could sing if i could
sing i i would probably i would probably
have the best voice the world has ever
seen if i could yeah yes
so anyway
that joke
i don't think he goes i don't think any
of his jokes are i think some listeners
are googling it just to find out if it
is actually a
joke is this a joke
no but now right now
you have a single out i do you have a
single out let's play that with snoop
dogg yes and dancing you have everyone
dancing to it there's a dance yeah dude
i can teach you which has become uh i
did the dance on on tick-tock no you
didn't you tried you yeah no i did it no
i did you tried but you can try a little
harder well
and that's what she said this thursday
the music video is coming out
this thursday it's last thursday i mean
it's it's been out it's there this is
not this is not long where are we next
week we're just on a podcast i don't
know what day this is
but it is out the video it just came out
[Music]
to play it yeah yeah we're allowed
it's out it's an electronic um dance
um song
i like it i heard it i like it
[Music]
you
wow
[Music]
i think this is the first time we've had
live performances that was a live
performance that was amazing
[Music]
you